before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
well it all starts
with a fall
[Music]
yes folks take two doctor who review is
back i've been putting this off uh for a
while basically i needed a bit more
distance from my initial viewings of
well any of the chris chibnall jody
whitaker era episodes before i felt like
it was worth revisiting them basically i
had to give enough time where my initial
gut reactions has time to wear off and i
can look at it a little bit more fresh
and also that you know enough time has
passed that theoretically my thoughts
may have changed and evolved that was
part of what was supposed to be the
appeal of when i first started doing
take who doctor who reviews
so
i think enough time has passed that we
can definitely do series 11 probably
series 12 we're definitely going to wait
on flux
for for a while there but we can
definitely get going on series 11.
and
i'll be up front
i have had a fair number of problems
with
most of this era i have not absolutely
detested it the way some people have and
i have and the things that i don't like
are not the things that the loudest
portions of geekdom have been screaming
about but i i have had some notable
issues
with the show both small scale and
little things that just felt careless or
not well thought out to some of the
bigger moves that like that
but this isn't an overview right now so
we need to deal with this just one
episode at a time we start of course
with the woman who fell to earth
[Music]
should be fine
now my original impression of this was
i'm going to go with middling i don't
think i thought that badly of it at the
time although i wasn't blown away with
it i think at the time it issued me
certain concerns that i'm like
i'm i had hoped for more and like to be
fair sort of the high benchmark for me
of modern era doctor who first the first
uh episode of a new doctor is 11th hour
and 11th hour is actually one of matt
smith's best episodes period so like my
scale is kind of skewed but i still
remember how good that was first time i
saw it and i can't help thinking
when something doesn't measure up to
that so
part of it's that that i can be a little
harsh but i'm going into this with the
same mentality that i went into any
episode or any season
uh sorry series
of doctor who
that i overall didn't like
because back when i did started doing
the take two doctor who reviews i said
that anytime i am watching something
that i know i didn't like the first time
i'm looking
for what works about it
and
failing that i'm looking to better
understand what didn't work or maybe
it's a little bit of both
and this time it's it's it's a little
bit of both there's actually some new
things they're not new problems but
they're things that i now see and make
me go oh
because there are things in here that
are
indicative of what are going to become
some recurring problems again for me
over the course of chibnall's time as
showrunner and i'll point some of those
out as i get there but i would very much
like to start with the positives
the show looks
great
and i noted this at the time the
artistry of the cinematography the
direction the integration of the effects
work
felt just
better like i love doctor who and it can
look good at times but it's
always been shot pretty basically for
the most part and this felt visually at
least
more ambitious and had higher
aspirations in terms of what it wanted
to look and feel like from a visual
aspect and i think it did that
very very well so
props to that right off the bat
uh the performances in this episode
are pretty solid
uh we'll get to jodie would occur in a
little bit but i appreciate her
performance here a bit more than i did
originally this is actually a little bit
what happened to me with uh say peter
capaldi who is now my favorite doctor
but i didn't take to him right off
partly because i was trying to wrap my
head around what his deal was gonna be
um with whitaker
honestly even at this point i still feel
a little bit at arm's length with her
doctor it reminds me a little bit of
peter davidson in that way and that's
part of the reason i'm not a huge fan of
peter davison as the fifth doctor as
well so i guess i'm consistent about
that but her performance is
solid uh the delivery of the lines the
sort of turning on a dime on topics
works well and there are some specific
moments that actually highlight her
ability to
um commit and bring something to these
lines quite well uh towards the end her
uh her little speech about having lost
family comes to mind carry them with me
what they would have thought
and said and done
make them a part of who i am i
really i like that line and i like the
way that she delivers that line
this is our first introduction to gram
yaz and ryan all of whom give about as
solid a first introduction to um
companion as you're gonna get without
seriously zooming in on the companion
which something like say rose or smith
and jones did or actually even 11th hour
did a bit when they really zoom in on
having you definitely get to know these
companions i could expect more but
new doctor
three companions story to tell i'm not
shocked we didn't get to know them in
any more depth but to the degree that we
do get to know them they are solidly
portrayed here a couple of more minor
things that i really like uh i love the
weird electric tentacle thing i love it
i love it for how weird it is i remember
i think i said when i reviewed it the
first time that it was kind of
lovecraftian not in a literal like
taking that aesthetic sense but in a i
don't even know what i'm looking at
since between the way it was designed
and the way it was shot especially when
it shows up on that train in the first
place
it was so weird and off-putting and i
didn't get it and i loved
all of that about it so again another
aspect of the visual presentation that
really felt well developed and well
thought out and was just good i enjoy
the montage of uh the doctor making the
new sonic screwdriver and i'm also gonna
highlight the soundtrack there
i feel like i see a lot of people
bemoaned the loss of murray gold and i
definitely get if you're in favor of his
more iconic kind of themes and the
bombast that he tended to bring to it
that yeah you'd miss that because that's
not what's going on now but that bit of
music while she's working on the new
sonic it's really good it's legit good
and it's worth highlighting because this
has been an era where the music has been
more background flavor and not something
that is as prominent in terms of being
up front and really telling you what to
do or think or what's going on it's been
a bit more atmosphere for the most part
but that's a good bit of music right
there i actually rather like carl the
guy from the train who they later after
save off the crane i like that we have
this collection of people who have
encountered this weird thing and most of
them are like going to cyber dog and be
like what do we do and this one guy's
like i'm leaving
i'm gonna go and i like that the show
doesn't feel like it's judging him for
that it's not portraying him as a coward
it's not portraying him as
incurious or illusory he's just like
he's this is too much and he can't deal
with it and i feel like the show and the
framing of the show kind of respects
that so i i like that he was there and
had that perspective and i liked the
show was respectful of it but of course
all that having been said
that there are
there are some
problems that i have with this and as i
said
some of them are indicative of stuff
that
is going to keep
coming up
um one of those is
i have a hard time sometimes wrapping my
head about around what
jody whitaker's versions of the doctor
what her morality is
uh because
like the doctor the doctor needs a moral
compass like always and the general
sense of that should be fairly
consistent from regeneration to
regeneration but the specifics about
what might get the doctor onto their
moral high horse those can and probably
should vary a bit
but there's a moment in this that just
struck me as bizarre this is towards the
end this is um after uh sim jaw is
basically defeated and the doctor tosses
him his
um his transport device so that he can
teleport away and
carl
kicks simshaw off
the
crane
and he zaps himself away and he's fine
and the doctor turns the car and says
you had no right to do that excuse me
first of all you effectively and
indirectly just set off five bombs in
the guy that were one apiece was
supposed to kill both you and all four
of the other people that you've been
tagging along with so first of all how
did you even know that you weren't about
to kill him when you did that to him
second of all the dude was fine he had
his transport thing he beamed out he was
fine
where are you
to just turn to this guy
who is scared and terrified and it's
just been through a harrowing experience
and did something in the heat of the
moment that maybe you would have had
more legitimate issues with had
simshaw like landed and died but like he
didn't
let the guy recoup
just turn on him and go you had no right
to do that and there's no follow-up on
that she just says it and we all move on
it's weird it's a very strange moment
and the doctor's moral compass is going
to be one of the things i'm going to
kind of have an eye out for because it's
something that i don't think i was
properly examining at the time that
these were originally airing but is
something that i've seen brought up um
in the discussion around the
characterization of the 13th doctor
since then
another example
of
something that is going to be a
recurring issue is that
honestly
the episode's kind of cruel
needlessly cruel
and i've got a couple of examples of
that so
for starters
i grant that first of all doctor who
tends to have a body count so
don't mistake me for com just
complaining about the fact that people
died
but
circumstances matter
so we have the guy who was hunting for
well
not really sims uh specifically but like
any stenza uh and he finds this one
because he wants to find out what
happened to his sister uh actually stick
a pin in that as a general concept we'll
come back to it because that's kind of
another thing but
i get that he's going to get killed
i get that
i don't really get what his plan was
hold on to that um but he's going to get
killed because we need to establish this
new alien threat as a threat and show
that he has no compuncture about killing
that having been established now
what is the point of the salad man my
salad
and what is the point
of the
guard at the gate
at the construction site because the
salad man is just a complete
non-sequitur we've already established
that
simsa has no compunction about killing
anyone
why do we have to have him
kill this person but even if i grant
that one where
maybe you could have made the argument
that simsa killed the original guy
because he felt threatened by him
whereas this guy was clearly no threat
okay like maybe maybe
i give you the salad man
i still think that's a really clunky way
to
convey that but like okay even if i give
you that
what is the point of taking a character
that you establish
within the first 10 seconds of seeing
him to be a loving caring grandfather
with a wonderful family back home not
every granddad's this lucky
and then immediately kill him
there is no reason to do that it makes
no point about the character that kills
him that has not already been made
elsewhere and it is needlessly
knife
twisting
it's going to come up again
at least once because very specifically
in uh
which one is it the the second of the of
the dalek new year's things
it
is going to happen again there where a
character is
um identified as being gay and then
immediately killed
first of all these characters dying
serve absolutely no narrative purpose
and you establishing one
theoretically sympathetic thing about
them before killing them just makes it
cruel
and
it's kind of a similar thing with grace
first of all grace is fantastic
i love her vibe i love that graham is
right beside her being like i don't know
about this and she's like no we need to
help i love her energy i love her uh
agency that she has she wants to get in
there and help and it makes total sense
for the background we know about her as
a caregiver it makes so much sense i
love grace there is no need to kill her
none
even if you're gonna make the argument
that well we're not gonna have her as a
regular companion and she's got the
personality that would go with the
doctor like okay fine except the entire
first trip that she takes with the fam
is an accident all you had to do was
have grace get injured so she was
staying at home recuperating while they
tried to help the doctor get back to the
tardis you still have the same ending
which i also don't really like because
it's a completely needless cliffhanger
that i already know gets resolved
incredibly uh anticlimactically and
through utter sheer coincidence
but
you did not need to kill grace
there is zero need for that again
it feels
cruel and yes i know doctor who can have
a body count but there's usually more
context to it than this you know we'll
see lots of people in a situation where
they are fighting or running from aliens
get mowed down and is that possibly
needless yeah in some cases it might be
but it's the fact that this episode and
other moments during chibnall's run that
he writes the time to give us a reason
to empathize with these characters and
then
kills them now he's not the only one to
do this moffatt did it too specifically
in
good man goes to war where we establish
this couple that are kind of cute and
then turn one of them into a headless
monk by taking his freaking head off so
like chipnel's not alone in doing that
but it felt more like an outlier when it
happened under other writers at least to
my memory correct me if i'm wrong about
that but it's something that is right
off the bat in the first episode of
chimney zera and i know it's going to
come up again
if anything good came out of grace's
death it is the funeral scene and the
speech from graham which is very nice
it's wonderfully heartfelt and it did
choke me up a little bit so that is well
delivered i still don't think it's worth
it for the loss of the character
what are you complaining about
i'm complaining because i wanted more
now i said we'd circle back to the guy
who's trying to find out what happened
to his sister
that also feels indicative of some stuff
that's going to go on later specifically
reminding me of flux in that it is
an element that needs way more
explanation than it gets to make sense
especially at the point at which it
becomes relevant because we have this
guy
who is you know who finds the
pod that looks like a freaking onion and
he takes it back to his place and he is
filming it he has some kind of intention
for it we don't know what it is so in
addition to not knowing what the friggin
onion thing is not knowing what the
tentacle ball is not knowing exactly
where uh the doctor's at in terms of
figuring out herself to be able to be
helpful and we're still trying to sort
all that stuff out you now throw in a
completely new character with a
motivation we will only ever barely
understand and by the time you explain
what his motivation was and what his
deal is he's already dead so what does
it matter
it feels reverse engineered it feels
like they decided we want to have a
camera uh
on the on the onion and to have somebody
record a video explanation of part of
what's going on and then
built a backstory for this character who
doesn't
like
he's both over and underdeveloped his
backstory is too complicated for how
much he actually matters to the story so
there's an over development but because
his backstory is overdeveloped he is
underdeveloped in his actual on-screen
time because we find all out about all
this after he's freaking dead
and again it reminds me a bit of flux
that kind of cramming something in where
uh we're already dealing with so much
stuff and you're gonna throw in this one
other thing that isn't gonna make sense
until later and then by the time you
find out it's like well why did that
even need to really be there in that way
so
things like that which
didn't necessarily irk me the first
viewing
now look like early warning signs for a
lot of stuff that's going to bother me
later on a few other quick things to
note i'm going to be keeping an eye in
addition on the doctor's sort of moral
compass i'm also going to be keeping an
eye on ryan's dyspraxia because another
thing that i saw brought up was how
inconsistent the show was in depicting
that um i will say here in its
introduction i think it's well handled
his
frustration with it the ways in which it
affects his life and his relationships
and i really like that after the funeral
grace's funeral he goes back up to the
hill and he starts trying again
and he keeps falling
because the terrible cheesy thing to do
would have been suddenly he can do it
which that's
nonsense
but
i like that instead
it's about him
taking her lesson about always getting
back on and trying again
so that was good
i do like nitpick thing i do really
wonder like
why were you trying to teach him how to
ride a bike on a
uneven bit of grass
like
i taught my kid how to ride a bike for
the first time a couple years ago
and you do it on pavement you do it on
something even so that they can get a
proper sense of how to just balance the
bike without having to contend with
uneven ground
i mean i suppose the reason to do it is
we get some very pretty shots up on that
hill so again visually very nice but
like
what why would you try and teach someone
to ride a bike there especially when
it's so far away from your house that it
requires a train ride
i
what oh the one other thing i meant to
mention about the the brother guy like
so he spent years trying to like find
the signal again track these these
aliens down he believes that they did
something horrible to his sister and his
plan is a video camera and a crowbar
like you figured out what signal
patterns to look for to get this thing
but you didn't think to
have any better precautions than a
crowbar
again it feels reverse engineered he's
not going to live anyway so there's no
point in giving him a better plan than
that because he's just going to get
killed regardless
it feels like
it feels like a narrative function
not a actually developed plot thread a
couple of other little things i don't
love the sheer bloody coincidence of the
doctor just happening to drop out of the
tardis into this exact spot um like it
would have been one thing if and i like
i'll watch for it but i don't think it
ever does if later got established that
the tardis dropped her there on purpose
because it knew she was needed there i'd
buy that but i'm pretty sure it is just
absolute sheer bloody coincidence that
she falls out of the sky into this train
where the stuff's going down and i don't
like that level of coincidence and it
doesn't help that it's about to be
repeated next freaking episode with
their rescue from space but we'll deal
with that when we get there jody's lines
are a little bit of a mixed bag because
i feel like and i'll keep an eye out for
this as well i feel like she's given
more just sort of lines for flavor here
than she is often later on it felt to me
often times with jody whitaker as she
went along playing the doctor that she
got saddled with so much of the
exposition that she rarely got the
chance just to have a line for character
or flavor or just to
have fun
and it always felt like every line she'd
say had to convey some kind of
information here she gets a little bit
more in terms of flavor lines than i
feel like she has later and when she
gets those she delivers them quite well
this could be a potential crisis
because you're a woman
am i
does it suit me everything from the half
an hour ago i used to be a white-haired
scotsman to the one i already mentioned
talking about lost family to even the
line that where she kind of reads yaz
and like yep but you're what are you
going to do call your superiors and tell
them what which is a little bit of an
exposition line in terms of covering why
diaz isn't going to tell her superiors
but like it is the doctor reading her
and getting a sense of her as a person
but then we've got
the other lines that that go on that are
just flat out explaining what's going on
and sometimes pointing out things that
would have been better left unsaid
like this
come on ryan come on yes i'm calling you
yes because we're friends now trust your
audience to have caught the fact that
yaz said that she's yes to her friends
and that the doctor just starts calling
her that
trust us to catch it please
so
it's it it's a mix start
and
i feel like i have a better appreciation
of what is good in this that i had the
first time i watched it but at the same
time i'm not sure that's actually
improved my opinion of it because now
i'm spotting things that i know are
going to be recurrent issues uh later on
as it goes along
and that's and that's something that i
didn't have on first viewing
but we'll see how this keeps going
the woman who fell to earth what are
your thoughts on it what do you like
about it what doesn't work about it be
respectful i know some people have very
heated opinions about this era
but like just be respectful of everybody
me each other the creators all right
drop your thoughts down in the comments
let's talk about it
patreon is how i am able to pay the
bills and keep this entire operation up
and running any amount is of great
assistance and there's perks for every
tier but uh there's other ways to help
me you can check me out on other social
medias as well um see ways to support me
there if you like or just the like share
and subscribe they help me out as well
and so i appreciate that
don't worry
too much about it though
because at the end of the day
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
it's the end credits means i gotta shout
out some patrons this month it is turok
oliver b linda walters tt
robin powell fronabilax the poodle idoln
tracy scrabbon dharma michael doyle
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
adam lefty taylor robin moore shayla
gourlay and bookworm
thanks so much for your support
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]